muchas personas se encuentran en los
problemas que involucran fuerza
centrípeta mucho más difícil es que
aquellos problemas que no la involucran
así que vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos
más de estos problemas y también vamos a
ver algunos errores comunes que la gente
comete con este tipo de problemas veamos
este ejemplo que es un clásico digamos
que tenemos un yoyo y lo vamos a girar
verticalmente llega hacia arriba y luego
va más lento este es un círculo vertical
no un círculo horizontal este yoyo está
girando verticalmente en el aire pero
para los propósitos de este problema
digamos que es una masa atada a una
cuerda la masa del yoyo es de puntos 25
kilogramos y la longitud de la cuerda es
de punto 5 metros y digamos que el yoyo
tiene una rapidez de 4 metros por
segundo cuando se encuentra hasta arriba
y algo que nos interesa conocer si
fabricamos yoyos es cuál es la atención
que puede soportar esta cuerda de acá
qué tan fuerte debe ser nuestra cuerda
para soportar este movimiento
en este problema nos preguntamos cuál
será el valor de la atención cuando el
yoyo se encuentra en la parte más alta
de su recorrido y va a 4 metros por
segundo y si es una fuerza lo que
queremos encontrar entonces lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es dibujar un buen
diagrama de fuerzas diagrama de fuerzas
tenemos que preguntarnos qué fuerzas van
a estar actuando en el yoyo y si este
yoyo se encuentra cerca de la superficie
de la tierra va a tener una fuerza de
gravedad que va hacia abajo esta fuerza
de gravedad
fg va a ser igual a m por g donde ge es
9.8 positivo y que representa la
magnitud de la aceleración debido a la
gravedad y esa expresión representa la
magnitud de la fuerza de gravedad pero
hay otra fuerza más esta masa está atada
a esta cuerda y las cuerdas jalan
ejercen una fuerza de tensión qué
dirección tendrá esta fuerza de tensión
muchas personas querrán dibujar esta
fuerza de tensión hacia arriba pero esto
no está bien las cuerdas no pueden
empujar y si no me creen vayan por una
cuerda y traten de empujar algo con esa
cuerda y se darán cuenta de que no es
posible pero algo que sí pueden hacer
las cuerdas
jalar la cuerda va a jalar con qué
fuerza aún no lo sé justamente es lo que
quiero encontrar esta va a ser nuestra
fuerza de tensión la denominamos con una
t mayúscula aunque también pudimos
denominar la con una f y una t pequeña
hay diferentes maneras de denominar la
pero sin importar como la llamen esta
fuerza de tensión va a estar apuntando
hacia adentro ya que esta cuerda está
jalando a esta masa y ya que dibujamos
el diagrama de fuerza cuando queremos
encontrar una fuerza típicamente vamos a
usar la segunda ley de newton
como siempre vamos a usar esta fórmula
en una dimensión cada vez vertical
horizontal o centrípeta la aplicamos en
una de estas dimensiones para mantener a
nuestros cálculos sencillos y ya que
tenemos un problema de aceleración
centrípeta ya que tenemos un objeto que
se mueve en una ruta circular y queremos
encontrar una de las fuerzas que van
hacia el centro del círculo pues vamos a
usar la segunda ley de newton en la
dirección centrípeta esta va a ser la
aceleración centrípeta y estas van a ser
las fuerzas centrípetas es decir la
reescribimos vamos a usar la segunda ley
de newton para encontrar la aceleración
centrípeta que es igual a la fuerza neta
centrípeta entre la masa del objeto que
está siguiendo esta ruta circular y ya
que elegimos la dirección centrípeta
vamos a poder reemplazar esta
aceleración por la fórmula de la
aceleración centrípeta
es la rapidez al cuadrado entre el radio
de esta ruta circular que sigue este
objeto y esto es igual a las fuerzas
netas entre p estás entre la masa y aquí
el truco está en elegir cuáles van a ser
las fuerzas que vamos a poner en esta
parte de las fuerzas centrípetas tenemos
que identificar cuáles son estas fuerzas
centrípetas y ponerlas aquí con el signo
que les corresponde cuáles son las
fuerzas que están en nuestro objeto pues
tenemos la fuerza de tensión y la fuerza
de gravedad así que aquí vamos a incluir
nuestra fuerza de gravedad algunas
personas no saben qué poner aquí pero no
se preocupen siempre usen su diagrama de
fuerzas para eso lo dibujamos nuestro
diagrama de fuerzas contiene toda la
información de las fuerzas involucradas
en este objeto siempre y cuando lo
dibujemos correctamente y así es como lo
hicimos todo esto está bien dibujado
pues incluimos todas las fuerzas tenemos
que analizar cada una y ver si éstas se
incluyen en nuestra segunda ley de
newton tenemos que preguntarnos voy a
incluir la fuerza de gravedad aquí bueno
para responder a esa pregunta tenemos
que ver si esta fuerza es una fuerza
centrípeta y recuerden que la palabra
centrípeta es una forma elegante de
referirnos a todo lo que se dirige hacia
el centro del círculo y aquí la gravedad
si se dirige hacia el centro del círculo
por lo que si la vamos a incluir aquí es
una fuerza centrípeta ya que está
contribuyendo a que esta masa siga esta
ruta circular así que la vamos a poner
aquí m porque es la magnitud de la
fuerza de gravedad pero tenemos que
decidir si ésta va a ser positiva o
negativa y muchas personas pensarían en
incluirla con signo negativo ya que
apunta hacia abajo
cuando trabajamos con direcciones
centrípetas la convención es que todo lo
que va hacia el centro del círculo tenga
un signo positivo y todo lo que va hacia
fuera del círculo radialmente tendrá
signo negativo por lo que no siempre
toda la dirección que va hacia arriba es
positivo podríamos tener en este caso
esta dirección que va hacia el centro
del círculo y es positiva pero también
tenemos esta que va hacia abajo y como
se dirige hacia el centro del círculo
también va a ser positiva cualquier
dirección no importa de donde venga pero
que se dirija al centro de este círculo
va a tener signo positivo y la razón de
esto de que todo lo que va hacia el
centro del círculo sea positivo es
porque nosotros elegimos que la
aceleración centrípeta tenga signo
positivo y ya que elegimos que esta
aceleración centrípeta que va hacia el
centro del círculo su dirección sea
positiva pues todo lo que tenga este
también tendrá su signo positivo si
decidimos que esta aceleración hacia
adentro del círculo es positiva entonces
nos comprometemos a que todo lo que
tenga esta dirección hacia el centro del
círculo tenga signo positivo es decir
también podríamos decir que la dirección
radial hacia fuera del círculo sea
positivo pero si hacemos esto entonces
nuestra aceleración centrípeta va a
tener que tener un signo negativo y esto
es un poco raro y por eso la gente no lo
hace si elegimos que nuestra aceleración
sea positiva lo que va a hacer que todas
las fuerzas que tengan esta dirección
hacia el centro radialmente también sean
positivas y regresando a nuestro
problema veremos que esta fuerza de
gravedad por esta razón que acabamos de
explicar va a ser positiva es una fuerza
centrípeta positiva porque se dirige al
centro del círculo y continuamos que
otra fuerza tenemos aquí pues tenemos la
fuerza de tensión la vamos a incluir
aquí sí sí la vamos a incluir porque es
una fuerza centrípeta se dirige hacia el
centro del círculo la incluiremos con
signo positivo o negativo
bueno como también se dirige hacia el
centro del círculo vamos a ponerla con
signo positivo así que aquí vamos a
poner nuestra fuerza de tensión
es una de las fuerzas que hacen que esta
masa se mueva en esta ruta circular en
otras palabras las fuerzas combinadas de
la gravedad y la atención van a formar
nuestra fuerza neta centrípeta aquí y si
ahora queremos despejar la atención
vamos a multiplicar ambos lados de la
igualdad por m y después vamos a restar
m por g si hacemos esto nos va a quedar
que la atención es igual a m por d al
cuadrado entre r - m por g nos va a
quedar que la atención es igual
5.55 newtons esto suena lógico ya que
estamos restando la fuerza de la
gravedad a esta fuerza centrípeta neta
por lo que este término de aquí
representa a la cantidad de fuerza
centrípeta que necesitamos para hacer
que este yoyo vaya en esta ruta circular
pero la tensión que necesitamos es la de
esa fuerza menos la fuerza de gravedad y
la razón de esto es que tanto la
gravedad como la atención están
contribuyendo a esta fuerza centrípeta
así que ninguna de ellas por sí sola
forma la fuerza centrípeta son ambas
juntas las que forman la fuerza
centrípeta y es por eso que la atención
no es tan grande como podría ser sin
embargo si consideramos el caso en el
que yoyo va a estar rotando
siguiendo esta ruta circular y ahora va
a llegar acá ahora nuestro diagrama de
fuerzas va a lucir diferente la fuerza
de gravedad va a seguir apuntando hacia
abajo aunque su magnitud siempre va a
estar dada por m por g pero ahora en
este caso nuestra atención va a estar
apuntando hacia arriba ya que la cuerda
siempre va a jalar las cuerdas nunca
pueden empujar así que esta cuerda va a
seguir jalando la masa de este yoyo
hacia el centro del círculo y ahora
cuando pongamos las fuerzas aquí una de
estas fuerzas va a tener signo negativo
antes en este caso ambas serán positivas
porque ambas iban hacia el centro del
círculo pero ahora sólo una es la que va
a estar apuntando hacia el centro del
círculo y vemos que es la atención la
que está apuntando hacia el centro del
círculo y ahora la gravedad está
apuntando hacia afuera del centro del
círculo
apuntando radialmente afuera del círculo
esto quiere decir que aquí la atención
va a permanecer positiva pero ahora para
este caso la fuerza de gravedad va a
tener que considerarse negativa es una
fuerza centrípeta negativa porque se
aleja del centro del círculo si
quisiéramos calcular la atención en la
parte de abajo de la ruta el lado
izquierdo seguiría siendo el mismo ya
que esta es la aceleración centrípeta la
masa de aquí abajo seguiría siendo m
esto no cambia pero en lugar de tener
temas m&g ahora vamos a tener t - m g ya
que la gravedad está apuntando hacia
afuera radialmente del centro del
círculo si ahora quisiéramos despejar la
atención nos quedaría que la atención es
igual multiplicamos la masa en ambos
lados de la igualdad y sumamos m g en
ambos lados de la igualdad
ahora tenemos este signo positivo algo
que agregamos a esta m por b al cuadrado
entre r mientras que en este otro caso
teníamos que arrestarlo lo cual tiene
sentido al menos conceptualmente ya que
aquí tanto la atención como la gravedad
estaban trabajando juntas para dar este
movimiento circular ambas colaboraban
para esta fuerza centrípeta de manera
que a una de estas no tenía que ser tan
grande como lo sería en otro caso en
cambio aquí abajo la gravedad no sólo no
está ayudando a la atención la gravedad
está perjudicando a la fuerza centrípeta
porque está jalando esta masa fuera del
centro del círculo por lo que en este
caso esta pobre tensión no solo tiene
que estar equilibrando la fuerza neta
centrípeta sino que tiene que equilibrar
aún más que esta fuerza centrípeta
simplemente para poder cancelar este
efecto negativo de la fuerza de gravedad
y si queremos poner los números para
encontrar el valor de la atención vamos
a tener exactamente este término de acá
pero en este caso tendremos que sumar la
fuerza de gravedad a esta fuerza
centrípeta neta y si hacemos todos los
cálculos nos va a quedar que la atención
es igual a 10.45 newtons en resumen
cuando resolvemos problemas de fuerza
centrípeta típicamente vamos a escribir
b al cuadrado entre el positivo del lado
izquierdo de la igualdad
nuestra aceleración es positiva y al
hacerlo determinamos que todas las
direcciones que vayan hacia el centro
del círculo van a ser van a tener signo
positivo ya que esta es la dirección
hacia la cual apunta nuestra aceleración
centrípeta lo que significa que todas
las fuerzas que se dirigen hacia el
centro del círculo van a ser positivas y
aquí hay que tener cuidado ya que
significa que algunas fuerzas que van
hacia abajo van a tener un signo
positivo al menos en las fuerzas
centrípetas
ya que todo lo que vaya hacia el centro
del círculo va a tener si uno positivo y
el que una fuerza sea positiva en un
momento del tiempo como aquí la fuerza
de gravedad no significa que siempre va
a ser positiva en otro momento que se
realice este movimiento